じゃああの9時までに終わらなくていけないっていうことがございまして
じゃあ読み上げることだけにします
これから読み上げるだけで十分です
何も損はしないと思います
ちょっと因果法則に絡んだんだからね
これはもうものすごい難しいんです
私たちの日々の生活 パターンから抜けて自由になりたいのですが
ということで しかし 一切はパターンです
物質についても心についても
仏教は因果法則を語るんです
で 因縁により現れないもの
起こらないものはありえないんです
この絶対的な状況をダンマティティタダンマニアメターと言うんです
もう絶対的 すべて因縁よりやと
だからパターンですよ
すべて法則の確実性 法則の方式性ということになるんです
なかなか日本語訳できない単語なんですけど
厳しい単語なんです 心を含む一切の現象に対する変えることはできない法則という意味です
もう変えることできない法則があるんです
これがパターンというもので
この法則に仏教は因縁
因果法則というんですね
そこで不満 怖い 逃げたい
社会の限りのないパターンに不安
脅威を感じる人もいます
この世の中でいろんなことあるでしょう
慣れる自信がなくなるんですね
社会に この会社にもうあまりにも複雑すぎて
もう嫌だと 慣れませんよと
学校も仕事も家族生活も
それで嫌になっちゃうんですね
学校もあまりにも複雑で
規則規則ばっかしで 学問にしたってもうガチャガチャややこしくて
もう慣れなくなっちゃう
パターンありすぎて そうすると恐怖感感じる
不安感じるんです 仕事の場合も同じこと
逃げて自由になりたいと思いますよ
そういう人々は 社会の中でどうにもならない
役にも立たない存在になるんです
そういう人々は だって学校に行ったら学校は嫌だ
あの勉強は嫌だ 仕事は嫌だ
毎日同じ人に会って同じことを嫌だ嫌だとかね
そういう人は自由になりたいつもりなんですけど
実質は社会に役に立たない
どうにもならない人間になるんです
自由挑戦者は 社会にとっては危険な存在になるんです
そういう人々がとても危険なんです
学校に行ってろくに学ばない
職に就かない 結婚もしないとか危ないんです
何するかわからないんです
だから社会にとっては迷惑
本人は自由に挑戦しているんですけど
逃げたがる人はだいたい社会を批判非難します
壊したいと思う その努力もする
社会を壊す 壊す努力もする
時々放火事件とかありますね
ああいう連中なんです
社会システムに従わないんです
社会の常識に従わない
これは自分に能力がないということ以外何でもありません
これ 特別なアイデアで
この自由を謳っている人々は
はっきり言えば何の能力もないんです
その自分に能力がないことを謳っているんです
私はそのシステムは嫌だとかね
それには従わないんだとかね
俺は俺なりに生きてみるぞとかね
ということは あなたには何の能力もないんだぞと
能力というのはシステムを学んで使用することです
定義しましたからね 自分に適応できないことは社会のせいにするんですよ
その人々は 社会が悪いんだと
そんなことを言えるんですかね
あなたが社会に慣れなさいでしょうに
しかし 一切はシステムです
因縁です パターンです
逃げられないのです 自由とは成り立たないものです
それも覚えておいてください
自由っていうのは成り立たないんです
何が自ら自由になりたいと思うようなものです
成り立たないでしょ 人間が自由になるって何考えてますかね
何が自ら自由になれる
波は自ら独立できません
限りのないパターンの中で生きている自分という小さなパターンをはめておかなくてはならないんです
そこで我々一人一人何するのかというと
自分というパターンというのはほんの小さなパターンですよ
自分は そこはこの巨大な社会というパターンで
どこにはめるのか こちらにはめたら OK
あ 動いてると それだけなんです
自分というピースは世界というジグソーパズルの中ではめる位置があるんです
これまた 一人一人の人間に自分のパターンを埋め込むところがあるんです
ないはずはありません
自分は全体的なパターンの一部です
一人一人の人間が人間というジグソーパズルのうちワンピースだからね
このピースは余ったとか何考えても余らないんです
能力のない人はわからないだけ
自分というジグソーパズルのピースをどこにはめればいいかと
だから必要なのは能力だけ
自分にできる範囲のパターンを学ぶか
努力して学んで能力を向上するか
どちらかする必要はあります
要するに できる範囲で生きてみるか
より良い生き方に挑戦するかです
人間にその道2つしかないんです
できる範囲で生きてみるか
あるいは派手に生きたければ頑張って能力を上げるか
注意 すべてを学ぶことはできません
だからすべて学ぶことはできませんよ
ただ 自分の人生をちょっとレベルアップして
ちょっと派手に生きたならば
ある程度の能力 ある程度のものを学ぶ
何かを学んだとしても
それは完全な能力にはならないんですね
人はどこかで手を打つんです
理性のある人は何でもやってやるぞとかね
世界制覇しようと思わないんです
どこかでここまで行って手を打たなくては
打つんです 逃げない挑戦者
学問にも仕事にも挑戦する
家族 人間関係などもうまくいくように挑戦する
このような人々は 人生に関わる様々なパターンを発見する
他人から学ぶ だから挑戦する人はまあ挑戦します
仕事にも学校にも教育にも挑戦する
結婚して家族生活にも挑戦する
子供が生まれたら子育てに挑戦する
それでわからないことは学ぶ
いろいろパターンを学んで学んで発見する
それからそのパターンにはめて従って安全に生きるという気持ちになる
このパターンにはめたら安全に生きるということになります
型で固まる世界 我々に定まった固定したパターンが無数にあります
この世の何でも前もって決まっているようです
経済 科学 政治 日常生活
人間との関係などにも決まった固定したパターンがあるようです
なんか見たらなんかパターンがあるんですね
経済学 自由じゃないんですね
決まりパターンでやりなさいと
政治家に自由な行動できないんですね
このパターンがありますからね
守りなさいと このパターンの中でしか動かないんだと
オバマさんの場合はね
宣誓する言葉が 憲法で決まっていて
パターンがあって それが裁判官が間違っちゃったんですね
オバマさんが暗記しているんですよ
だから暗記していますけど
しきたりは裁判官の後で言うんです
裁判長が間違うんです
でお互い並べてみたっても
裁判官 何の能力もないオバマさんがすごい能力者だと見えますよね
だからその時でもね 本当オバマさんが立派でしょ
ニコッと笑うんですよ
知っていて やっぱりさすが大統領やと思いますよ
その人はなんとか世界の問題はなんとかもうするでしょうとは期待できますよ
はい それを置いておいて
パターンでしょ そこをもうこのパターン間違ったんだから
また自分の事務所でもう一回宣誓をやらなくちゃいけなくなったんです
パターンに従える場合も
失敗することもありますよ
そこでパターンに従おうと思っても
我々は失敗することはあります
で 大きな間違いがありますね
現象があるパターンに固定しているというのは大きな間違いです
だから経済学ならこうであるべき
政治はこうであるべきというのは大きな間違いなんです
例えば オバマさんがたった一つの言葉が間違ったんだから
だから大統領としてはもう成り立ってない
どんなバカバカらしい話ですかね
あれは バカバカしい あまりにも原始的迷信でしょ
また事務所で人まとめたところで
また手を挙げてもう宣誓すると
それしなかったら大統領じゃないんだという
いかにアホらしいかと
戦争で勝った それから前の人が出ていった
その次の 1 分から大統領
それで終わりでしょうに
なんで？なんで何人かんでもこの決まってるパターンがあると思うんですかね
いわゆるパターンが定めていると
パターンがあるんだけど
定めてないんですよ そこがみんなわかってないところ
経済学にはまるっきり違う経済学があって
何が悪いんですかね 例えば日本の憲法はそんなまま捨てちゃって
まるっきり新しいものを作っても何が悪いんですかね
あ 憲法はまるな 憲法は 50年も古いんですけど
今時代変わってますけど
そこが人間のまずいところなんですね
あまりにもこの後退心で先進的じゃないんです
それではパターン知ったとは思わないんですね
世間が知る因果法則ではそのようになります
世間のガタガタの因果法則では
社会のあるべき形 経済のあるべき形
家族のあるべき形 うんうんうんうん
あるわあるわ あるわ 現在
現象を固定して安心しようとするのは
因果法則ではありません
このあるべき形という概念で保守的になると
後退心になると これとても良くないんです
仏教は逆にいつでも精神
精神 精神 進歩 進歩 進歩と
止まるなよと 進めと 社会に対しても止まるなよと
物質の心の因縁に従う従った正しい生き方にもなりません
だから固定しちゃうと
形があると思っちゃうと
因果法則に逆らっています
それは物質の法則に逆らっているし
心の法則にも逆らっているんです
これが最悪なんです 一切の現象に関わる絶対的な
変えることは不可能な因縁性を発見しなくてはならないんですよ
だから 本物の因果法則を発見してほしいんです
すべてのものを支えている
一切のものを支えている
この基本の基本的な因果法則
絶対的な因果法則 お釈迦様がそれを発見したんです
原子爆弾を作る因果法則じゃないんです
そこで発見するのは いかなる現象であっても固定するものではなく
変わってしまうものだという事実です
固定は成り立たないとお釈迦様が発見したんです
形っていうのは成り立たないんだと
すべて流動的だと 一瞬だけだと
だから あるべき姿 あるべき形
バカバカらしいんです
パターンにはめて生きているから
物事がそのまま流れるならば安心します
我々はね 楽になります
失敗もストレスもない
しかし 退屈でになります
ロボットになります 生きがいがなくなります
だから 現代人にはそういうことはある
退屈で生きがいがなくて
もうパターンをいくらか知って
そこにはめて止めるんです
パターンにはめるんですよ
はめるんだけど 止めてはならないんです
そのちょっとしたポイントなんです
破れないパターンを無意味に変えようとして失敗するか
暗く光もなく生きるかですね
現代人は それで止まって壊れる
止まるんだから止まれないのに
現代のように経済不況などに陥ったらどうすることもできなくなっているんです
だって決まってるパターンで生きてるでしょ
形がありますから 決まってる形
株なら上がるべきだと
だからこんな羽目になるんです
期待していたものと違ったことが起きたら何もできない
マニュアルがないと生きていけませんね
最初はいくらか能力があったが
慣れてしまえば能力はなくなっているんです
我々の可哀想な生き方っていうのは
最初はいくらか能力があるんですよ
それで何か学ぶんですよ
学んでもう何か職に就くんですよ
時々人々はすごい頑張って政治家になるんですよ
なって議員になったところでピタッと止まるんです
全部成長は そこでパターンを守るんです
役に立たないんです 止まって壊れる人生です
止まると壊れますよ そこは覚えてほしいんです
ですから ポイントは無常ということです
因果法則を一言言葉でまとめると
無常という真理なんです
パターンのみでできている
パターン以外に何もない
人生は基本的に無常というパターンだと知って生活することは中道であり
正道です 難しいんですけど
説明する時間はございません
そういうのはもう なかなか日本語でも書けない
かなり意味深い文章です
大体そのまま覚えるしかないんです
パターンでできています
全部パターンのみ パターン以外何もない
しかし 無常です 無常も以上パターンです
現れたものは消える それもみんなパターンですね
現れたら消えるパターン
こう を理解してほしいんです
だから止まってはいけません
いわゆる止まることは不可能です
毎日毎日毎日変わるんだだから変えなさいよと
変わるとどんないうふうに変わるかわからないでしょう
変えちゃえば自分好きなように変えられます
世界は無常を思考の計画の基準にしてないので
問題を起こすんです 世界の思考では問題ばっかし
仏教の思考では問題ゼロです
理由は 仏教の思考ではいつでも無常があった上の政治学
無常があった上の経済学
無常があった上の社会学なんです
だから問題は起きません
では 自由とは何だと すぐ終わります
自由より柔軟性だと理解した方が無難です
だから自由という言葉ではなくて
柔軟になりましょう もっと柔らかくなります
自由はないんです すべてはパターン
因果法則ですからね 真の自由は因縁性を乗り越えると成り立つものです
自由というのはあるんですけど
それは因縁性を乗り越えなくちゃいけないんです
したがって 解脱以外自由は存在しないんです
だから自由という言葉は仏教だけ語っているんです
実質的に  言葉だけはありますけどね
しかし 解脱にも達する方法がありますね
残念ですけどね 全てパターンだからね
パターンにはめた はめられている人がパターンから脱出するためのパターンがあるんです
はい これからポイントを並べて終了します
講演のポイントではなくて
講演で言えなかったポイント
1人生をパターンにパターンすることで本人が安心する
2何も考えなくて困らなくても物事は進む
それで発展成長などは果たして期待できるでしょうかと
パターンにはめただけでは
4 物事が恵まれる 目まぐるしく変化している世界では生きていられるんですかと
あんた方はパターンにはめて止めたら
対応性はどうなるんですかね
我々の  6 ひらめき 新鮮なアイデアなどはどうなることでしょうかと
7 特に無常に適合することはできなくなるでしょう
これがとても必要です
真理ですから 無常はね
それに適合しないと 無常に逆らうと
それで人生人は壊れていくんです
9 パターンはそれでも断言的に否定することも
無視することもできない
悪いと言えるものでもないんです
パターンは  10 慣れてないものを習うために復習する
11 瞑想実践も善行為も繰り返してやることで慣れるんだから
何でも繰り返してやって慣れてくださいと
一回やっただけではダメだと言われるんじゃなくて
何回も繰り返してパターンに慣れるんです
これは瞑想にしたっても
解脱にしたって同じことです
繰り返しやるという  12 繰り返して行うことは脳の開発でもあります
発達でもあります  13 パターン因縁だからこそ
実践する 習う 成長する
発展するなどは成り立つんです
すべて因縁だからこそ
発展も可能 成長も可能
習うことも可能 向上することも可能です
解脱も可能です 因縁だから
14 しかし 型にはめるのは成長の筆頭に釘を打つことです
それで終わり  15 仏教とは
成長と自由を目指して
真理であるパターン 因縁の法則を巧みに利用する
それが仏教徒の生き方なんです
因縁を巧みに利用するんです
だから日常生活も成功する
死後も成功する 解脱にも達すると
何も存在しないんです
仏教の世界は はい それで以上です
はい 時間5分過ぎましたので
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]